c'est l'une des compétitions les plus
attendus de l'année pour les clubs
locaux
la finale interdépartementale des
équipes fédérales étaient organisées à
montigny le bretonneux
avec à la clé une bonne dose de stress
avant le début des épreuves
au début ce n'est pas stressant mais dès
qu'on arrivait vent au stress mais après
on
on s'y habitue ces valeurs que fait donc
près sûr qu'il faut être entraînés
experts au programme quatre agrès pour
les 650 gymnastes âgés de 17 19 ans les
participants se sont essayés au saut au
sol à la barre et à la poutre
alors la poudre sans aucun cas c'est
compliqué parce qu'il faut savoir
appréhender la peur et les choses comme
ça c'est vrai qu'il ya certains
mouvements qui sont plus compliquées qui
nous font peur et du coup il faut qu'on
apprenne à gérer notre stress mais quand
quand on doit faire des mouvements des
sauts des choses comme ça parfois ça
fait un peu peur d agréer qu'il a fallu
dompter pour impressionner les juges de
la compétition les gymnastes ont été
notées sur les codes du pointage
décliner des notations internationales
il y à une note d qui permet qui leur
donne des points en fonction des
éléments qu'elles ont produit et une
note
eux qui est de la note d'exécution qui
les pénalise surtout technique faute ou
les grosses fautes qu'elle en fait les
juges ont notamment été impressionné par
montigny le bretonneux le club
organisateur est reparti avec trois
médailles dont un titre en individuel